- I have to ask
because we are a few days
from Valentine's Day.
So do you and Warren celebrate?
Do y'all?
'Cause it's been many years, so.
- It has been many years.
So are you like no pressure
kind of Valentine's day?
Or do you still go for it?
- It's pretty no pressure.
I mean, we are 30 years married
in March.
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
- How long have you been together?
- 31.
- 31, okay.
Right on, right on.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot of years.
- It's a lot of years.
- Yeah.
- And we're both very proud of that.
- [Kelly] I would be too.
- We have four kids.
I mean, it's a lot of life,
but Valentine's is pretty low key.
He will generally make
me a little Valentine,
like with just a little red felt pen.
- Yeah.
Make a little heart,
and he's very economical
(audience laughing)
in his message.
- But is it thoughtful though?
'Cause I feel like we can
buy whatever we wanna buy
if we wanna present, you know?
So I like thoughtful.
- Yes, and there's nothing.
- Just so you know.
You just keep that in your mind.
- There's nothing to buy for him.
He's like one of those men.
You cannot find anything that he-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah, it's just he's,
so no, it's usually something small.
It's a little note.
It's a flower, it's a-
- I love that.
- Yeah.
30 years, way to go.
(audience applauding)
So what about you?
You are your wife, what do y'all do?
- Well, we've been married 18 years,
so doing really good at that.
- Okay, okay.
- Not bad, is it?
- 18 years.
- [Kenneth] Not bad.
- [Annette] That is not bad.
- Not bad.
I do bad poetry.
So that's a...
(Kelly laughs)
No, I mean bad poetry.
And she waits for it every year.
Her eyes roll
on Valentine's Day morning
(Annette laughing)
as she opens the thing,
which usually goes something like,
"Roses are red, violets are blue.
You need the bathroom, but I use the loo."
(Annette and Kelly laughing)
That kind of thing.
(laughs) I mean, I wish it
were a bit more Shakespearean,
but that's,
- Oh my god.
that's as far as I can go.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I love it though.